- Have you ever wondered how much one
of these actually cost Apple to make?
Unfortunately, the company
doesn't release official profit margins
for its devices.
That's why I reached out
to Counterpoint Research
for material cost breakdown.
Some parts of the new phone are cheaper.
But Apple kept the price we pay the same.
Why is that?
Let's look at what the researchers found.
- [Narrator] The best
iPhones we've ever created.
- The iPhone 14 Pro Max
is the newest, priciest
and most feature-rich phone
you can get from Apple.
It has the biggest display,
a more advanced camera
and the fastest iPhone processor.
So how much does all that
contribute to its cost?
Let's take a look at this chart.
As you can see,
the most expensive parts were the always
on display and the processing components.
Together, they make up
about 40% of Apple's costs.
The cellular parts cost about 13%.
The cameras including the
new 48 megapixel main camera
only account for 11%.
Other small parts like
the buttons, speakers
and internal controllers
make up the remaining costs.
Overall, Counterpoint says Apple pays
about $464 for the parts of this phone.
That's a tad bit more
than what Apple paid for
the iPhone 13 Pro Max.
Despite the $17 rise in material costs,
Apple kept the retail price the same.
Generally what it costs
to make an iPhone trends
upward over time.
There are two big reasons for this.
Number one is innovation.
Premium phones keep getting better
and they have to to get your attention.
Analysts suspect Apple
will continue raising prices
to offset innovation.
- As you continue to see
more of that innovation
and giving the consumers
more of what they want
on that side of things,
pricing will continue to go higher.
- [Dalvin] The original
iPhone reportedly cost Apple
about $218 to make.
One of the biggest jumps
came a couple years back
between the basic iPhone 11
and the basic iPhone 12.
Adding 5G to the iPhone 12,
switching from LCD to OLED screens
and other changes raised the cost 26%.
The 5G components alone tacked on $34.
But now 5G is the industry standard
and the reverse is starting to happen.
The parts that enable cellular service
are cheaper than the previous generation.
Number two, inflation.
Adjusted for that, a
$649 iPhone 6 from 2014
would be about $896 today.
But over time, you do start to get
more for your money.
- A big strategy of Apple is actually
to use lower component prices
to pack more great content.
So essentially pushing more
of the cost benefits to the consumer
through more content.
- [Dalvin] These percentages
are just calculated estimates
because Apple's deals
with suppliers are top secret.
While the iPhone maker
releases an annual list
of its suppliers, it doesn't say
how much business it
does with each company.
Nor does it describe
what the suppliers do.
One way Apple is dealing
with those rising costs
is by designing more parts in-house.
Analysts say adding more homegrown parts
to devices should help bring costs
down over time.
- If Apple wasn't getting
a cost benefit internally
designing their own chips,
they probably wouldn't be doing it.
- Apple declined to
comment on this report.
But the company does
control the vast majority
of smartphone industry profits.
And pushing premium pro-level devices
helps it retain that lead.
- (indistinct) Bigger benefit for Apple
than other hardware makers out there,
like PC vendors is Apple's brand allows it
to really sustain its elevated prices.
- This strategy is important
to Apple's biggest
smartphone competitor, too.
Samsung's high-end phones are also sold
for more than twice the cost of materials.
The report doesn't tell
us how much Apple spends
on other critical parts
of its planning and distribution.
We still don't know how much Apple spends
on sales and marketing,
shipping, or even retail
but the report does offer a decent glimpse
at what you're actually paying for.
(upbeat music)